love this guy i love his uh love his
attitude love his moxie love uh
love love his pod busting with the boys
he's the co-host with some guy named
will compton
uh he is none other than taylor lewan of
your tennessee titans how are you taylor
hi ben rich i'm uh electrostatic to be
here as always
um i gotta be honest with you yep a
little upset what i'm listening to
before you bring me in trace atkins yeah
and his beautiful voice
how deep it is and then you bring me on
who's just as big as him
but i sound like i'm 12. so there's a
bit of a yin yang
here i'm a little frustrated but uh well
as always we'll work through it
let's appreciate the bus with the boys
of course your pod is killing it right
now
taylor it is absolutely crushing it you
had you made your pod made some serious
news the other day
with uh johnny manziel telling his
stories spinning a yarn or two
in your bust that is true that was
something else did you
did you know that story before he starts
talking about how he was signing stuff
uh and his hotel rooms and things like
that and uh have you ever heard that
from his college guys i've heard you
know you hear the old ghost stories and
uh what everybody did i i believe on
that podcast i said i wish i had the
opportunity to maybe get catch a couple
bucks here and there but michigan you
know how they roll man
they're straight edge they keep it right
and they do it the right way and
uh when when johnny got on there i told
him before the show as i tell every
guest before the show
we're not here to crush you or make you
look bad anything you want us to take
out we will
johnny told that story and i never got a
text so that thing rolled baby
and uh hey yeah people took it people
took it and ran with it but
i love how he uh he made he said he said
i won the heisman then i did x y and z
yeah and and
that is they can't reggie bush him they
can't do that well his
his line uh his best line was him saying
let
let them take my chick-fil-a bowl
[Laughter]
go ahead and take my nine and four
chick-fil-a ball go f yourself i believe
[Applause]
that was laugh out loud quote i was
laugh out loud
that guy man i tell you what the trials
and tribulations that johnny manziel has
gone through
being parallel to him in a certain way
being in the 2014 draft
being all-american with him i believe in
2012 and watching this guy on top
of the tops and then having his career
go the way he he did it did
you know having a guy like will compton
that does the bus with me yes
you know guy like will undrafted has
grinded his way through eight seasons
going into his ninth season
you know guy like him given giving
johnny the bird like how could you mess
this up and
johnny came on there he was humble he
handled himself well
i was very impressed his humility and
how he's kind of dropped his sword and
said you know what i guess i just never
really loved football
which is a which is a difficult thing
for some people everyone you know how it
is you play high school ball and
everyone's like
yeah you know i would have been
all-american and probably started but my
coach hated me that whole vibe
but johnny had no excuses man he put it
all on himself and i was very impressed
taylor lawan of the tennessee titans and
his pod with will compton bussing with
the boys available where all podcasts
can be acquired right here
on the rich eisen show how are you
feeling how's that knee you're good
he's great man uh i have my uh my pt
personnel
i never know whether to call her a pt or
or what a physical therapist
it's all the same thing but anna hartman
out of movement rev anybody out there in
california looking for a mentorship
movement rev man okay she comes in
during the season
i feel like i got hit by a truck and
then all of a sudden it's like it never
happened she does an amazing job and so
she's made my knee
feel amazing throughout these last seven
months and i'm very excited for the
season
i'll tell you what it takes an injury to
make you miss practice because no one
likes doing practice
i cannot wait to be exhausted in august
playing with the boys again
so that's when you're going to get back
out there like uh
there there's been no uh on field for
you
just yet you're you're no uh ota for me
has been a uh
a zoom meeting and getting getting right
and staying in my
stay in my lane and my schedule of what
it's been my workouts and strengthening
and and being smart about this thing no
one wins a game
uh engine you know i mean you you to be
able to take mental raps watch the film
that's the best i can do right now
i think if push came to shove it was
super bowl i you you bet i'd be out
there but
um for right now the team brabel we've
all agreed that the best thing for me is
to keep
healing up and getting ready for camp
and i i've never been so excited for a
football season in my entire life okay
so taylor
since you know uh now that you're part
of this world of the paparazzi
and and clicks and the importance of
being relevant
chris can you uh please uh post taylor
lawan says the titans are going to the
super bowl yeah just i just heard those
words
i mean i heard him say right if you took
if you took all the sentences i said and
yes did your own little thing with it
yeah
you could say that i said that however
right if
people who don't usually listen to the
whole thing just look at the headlines
if they dare read a little further
i did not say that rich and i appreciate
you trying to put me in this situation
rachel will really enjoy showing this in
a team meeting all right so
that's like two fire emojis guarantees
super bowl yeah well you said that if
there was a super bowl he'd play
right so how else should i take that he
said if it's a super bowl you'd play
like you plan on playing in the super
bowl thus
you guaranteed it right there
i get it all right yeah listen i'm
feeling a little i'm feeling back into a
corner here rich
[Laughter]
and it's 71 degrees in this room but i'm
sweating i don't like how i'm feeling
right now okay
okay i might have i might have skipped a
few parts guaranteed
if the super bowl was today yes and
they're like tail are you suiting up or
not yes
sevens is going to be on the field
playing left tackle that's that's the
stamp that's a long stamp guarantee
who are you playing in the super bowl
who are you playing yeah who are you
playing in the super bowl
who's what super bowl uh tough to say
dude i'm
[Laughter]
if you were playing in this hypothetical
situation you have to go who won the
last
super bowl well done which would be uh
which would be tampa bay there you go
and i guess we would be playing them i
guess i'd be looking over at tom's
you know right 75 billion dollar smile
his beautiful head of hair okay
and uh watching him okay throw
interceptions to the boys and hopefully
we're winning that game instead parallel
universe there you go taylor lawn uh
here on the rich eisen show says he can
take out uh jason pierre-paul um
and he's feeling good enough to take on
and dominic and sue in the super bowl
can you post that i got a great story
about jason paul um
we practice against tampa bay two years
ago it's when he either first got there
a year after that obviously after the
firework
incident with his hand and we do
one-on-ones
and jpp puts a move on me literally puts
me in the blender boys like
goes left i go left he goes back right i
go back right one thing leads to another
i'm spinning in a circle and he's hit
the quarterback
and he looks at me and he goes and i did
that with only one hand
and he kept walking and i was like oh my
gosh he took every firepower away from
me
he literally he took he took the fact
that he had less fingers than me
and used it as an advantage i don't know
how he did it it was unbelievable he
lives in my head rent free right now
taylor lawn here on the rich eisen show
so if you've been
zooming and that's the way that you've
been participating um
so you have not laid eyes on new titan
julio jones and his number two just yet
have you i'm i'm a fan of instagram and
i i've seen him
do his drills uh in the number two
jersey
guy looks great i mean first style hall
of famer obviously
as a fan as a player on the team i'm
super excited to have him on the team i
think
any team he would have gone to makes
that team better i'm just happy it's
part of the tennessee titans now
what does that mean uh taylor
that your front office is aggressive
the general manager john robinson and
the ownership
and the coach and you know everybody is
aggressive
and says we're gonna do this we're gonna
do this now and we have the window and
we're gonna put him with aj brown
and we've got derrick henry and we've
got lawn coming back and
and and tannehill is just as good as
he's ever been
and let's go like that's got him that's
gotta be a jolt
i'd imagine that's a great it's a great
feeling i think um
i think any office the way the way john
runs his business and does this thing i
like people always ask oh you think
we're going to do this i think we're
going to do that anybody who's listening
to the show that ever
wants to ask me a football question fun
fact i have zero idea what's going to
happen
with our personnel because john keeps it
close to the vest but he does a great
job
and i remember being a part of this the
team in 2014
going 2 and 14 and thinking this is this
is the nfl like these
this is what we do and then now being in
2021 being with the same team and
looking at the personnel we have
uh the talent that john's been able to
put on our team
and uh the coaching staff the way they
put in this position to be successful
it's crazy to think that i've been a
part of the same franchise for so long
seeing how it was back in 2014 and how
it's just
upgraded and developed and has become
you know a franchise that any player
would be happy to be a part of
now when it comes to all this talent
being on one team
doesn't say you're going to win a super
bowl it says hypothetically if
i was able to play today i play a super
bowl see i went back on that yes
but it doesn't say we're going to win a
super bowl what it means is
we have talent and but as any team goes
you have to put the chemistry together
right we have to
me and roger stafford got to get back
out there got to start feeling each
other out
you know i got to come back from this
knee uh julio and ryan's got to gel aj's
got to keep doing what he's doing and el
tractorcito man's got to get his carries
i think um
a lot of people are looking at all those
guys and they're not thinking about
anthony the turkey foxer man
a little quick on a dime all right a
little harvard grad guy's smart and he's
twitchy
i think we have a lot of potential but
you know i think with old phrases
potential means you haven't done
anything yet i think that's where we
stand right now taylor lawn on the rich
eisen show aj brown was on uh
just a couple days ago he says that uh
derek henry
runs the weight room that he basically
the the music the volume
all of that is that is that an accurate
assessment
well i used to be the oldest guy in the
weight room uh
he gets to run the the music right and
so back then it was you know
michael ruse and then it went to brian
oracpo
and then uh i think derek henry is one
of those memes that's like at the coin
flip and he's so big it's like heads or
tails and he says we'll take the ball
and the rest goes
okay i think that's kind of how it works
now so derek walks in
derek whatever you want to do buddy it's
up to you i got my own i got my own
music going up on top of the head i can
do whatever i want in there so
he can run whatever he wants yeah man
we're looking at that workout right now
the the outstanding which one the guy
post all day
no it's the monster chain link
around his neck and then he's doing uh
push-ups
using the um the elastic band
um as his bar and then you know the ball
as the where to rest his feet i mean
that's insane
that's just insane what would happen if
we found out that that was all just foam
weights
at all and there's been tricking all of
us he's just bred that way he just looks
that great
and actually doesn't lift he just goes
yeah let's get the foam 45 pounds on put
405 on and we'll make it look like i'm
doing something today what if it was
like that
well uh taylor lawan uh put put what
tweet are you putting up now chris
yeah so i'm gonna put up another tweet
uh daryl juan calls out
teammate uh for a country fake fake off
fake deep fake workouts deep fake
muscles fake workouts
by the way that's a great fantasy team
name deep friend
that sounds like a perfect deal for me i
cannot wait to go into mandatory mini
camp next week and uh
look at derrick and hopefully not have
to get in the fight well you know
you know we we come up with the memes
and the nicknames on the show
uh i i had aj brown on again as i
mentioned and we came up with a
a fantastic four uh meme and put all the
you know aj and and uh derek and ryan
and also julio's faces on it and
um call it the ten tastic four and
you took uh you took a offense
to this right it's not if i was
scrolling through my feed
like any old slump right yeah and i were
to see that i'd go oh wow the rich eyes
and crews got a little bit of an
imagination that's wonderful i love the
way they're developing and getting with
the times in their old days
i would think i'm so excited but instead
i have to go to my notifications where
i'm tagged in something
and i have to look at aj derek julio and
tannehill
and it's the ten-tastic whatever it's
like hey listen
if you're gonna tag the boy in it give
me like a cloud in the background or
it's a silhouette of my face or
something at least oh you know
taylor you did create a little bit of
dissension in the studio here
because i did throw tj jefferson uh
under the bus for saying i can't be
responsible for my staff and he's like
it's your idea that did not include
taylor
but tj it was your choice to to tag
taylor lawan i did not say
tag taylor lawn well why what i mean
taylor one is a friend of the show here
rich so i like that he's on the phone
you don't have to talk to him look at
taylor tell her you're a friend of the
show and i always like to tag you
in the boys of the show tj thanks to you
what did you say
sorry what'd you say taylor did you say
i said i i'm
a friend of the show but i'm wavering
towards acquaintance of the show
now i have to look like an idiot and ask
siri what dissension means after i get
off the phone
yeah there was a little bit of uh there
was a little bit of arguing with each
other
it was a little bit of yeah it uh but
it's okay okay what's that all about can
tj just tell you can you
go ahead and uh let me know like what
gives buddy are you a michigan state fan
no i don't like to be the catfish thing
no taylor i'm a taylor lewand fan and
you know like i said anytime we do
titans i like to include the boys in
in with them so that's all right that's
all it was just want to you know include
you into it
feelings were hurt hey before i let you
go i
also uh couldn't help but notice you
with the country music awards
and uh a great uh post of yours
was retweeting a photograph of you with
trace atkins
and um saying that you lost them with
your
choice of pants basically yes right what
happened well how'd you get here i'll
tell you
uh trace is um tracy's a legend he is
he's a guy i grew up watching got the
deep voice i remember my mom
talking about having a crush on him when
i was like 12 and i'm like how cool is
this
hey my mom wanted to date you didn't say
that thought it
but now i i literally i see him on the
red carpet i'm excited
he looks uninterested and i go up i
shake his hand he just looks at me and
grunts and goes ugh
do you wear your wife's pants to this
like i've lost them
i've lost everything all because of a
choice of a pair of pants but i'll tell
you what chris derosa
rosa she's the woman that uh styled me
for this event took uh
48 hours i told her hey i need something
yeah because i was told so late
and i think she put together a nice
little miami
drug dealy kind of feel vibe that i
personally really enjoyed
that's yeah it doesn't really speak to
country music in a way but uh
it's it's it's you um and that's pretty
cool man that you were able to do all of
that
um it was very cool this city this city
has been awesome to me and it's just
cool to be a part of it man i love uh i
love nashville
i i know that you're you're you love it
too so you know uh father's day as well
i saw you celebrating your
your fatherhood and being best dad ever
uh by crushing a beer
uh at a preds game right next to your
daughter
well done what did you what did your
daughter say to you after daddy crushed
a beer
right next to her well uh how'd that go
daddy made up that he made a personal
decision not to not to ingest any of
that beer because he's still
rehabbing me and didn't want that
information but on the car ride home
she gave me a very stern talking to her
it wasn't nice to pour water on her and
mommy
oh it wasn't a beer it wasn't better
next time
i was i just looked back at her i said
you wish it was water
she gave you a stern what's her name
again what's her name her name is win
rebel
dude i love her she's outstanding i love
it
hey thanks for the call you know i i do
love busting uh
compton's uh cajones by just uh acting
like he's
not even on your pod with you i don't
know why i enjoy i don't know why i
enjoy doing that
i don't know why i've never really i
don't really know him that well
but the ironic thing about that whole
thing is that will does literally all of
the work
is the so the man behind the scenes also
that's crushed this podcast to be able
to make it what it is
but i'm all about taking the credit i
think it's i think it's only good for us
well you're killing it when is the motor
arriving so i can be on this podcast
we got a trailer now we can throw that
thing to wherever you need us to be
buddy
so what are you talking about that does
look like that there is a motor with
inside that
budweiser bus of yours right there dude
yeah there is a motor
and but it doesn't have ran since 1976 i
believe so
i think i don't think that things
gearing up anytime soon hey
if the rich eisen show is the show it
claims to be
they will give us the money to fix the
bus oh that's
yeah we've got the budget for that
producer's listening and they really
want to be who they are
they would they would send it on
portnoy's got that in his couch cushion
you know that question but just because
he's got it there's gonna set it on me
man he's got pizza reviews to do
seriously like i see the videos like
he's probably betting as much with big
cat on tonight's games than than
your motor costs come on let me help you
out i don't i don't doubt that at all
the other thing is too you told us in
the podcast you can go subscribe five
stars
he throws in the podcast that people
think he doesn't bet his own money he's
betting his own money he's riding and
dying with the fans also
so all the emotions are real for those
guys obviously your boy can't bet
neither can this boy that's when i get
my cold sweats too and these guys talk
about gambling terms that totally
confuse me
with talking about fanduel i'm like oh
please god leave me out of this i cannot
i'm not shoeless joe jackson right i
can't
wow you're the man taylor take care of
yourself thanks for the call
let's let's catch up during the uh the
training camp season enjoy getting back
with your teammates
next week sounds wonderful thanks for
having me on guys everybody thank you
everybody except for tj have a great day
that's jeff garlitt jeff garland has a
problem with tj jefferson
because of the april fool's gag about
putting up a meme of russell wilson
being a chicago bear
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here